sospechoso de ocasionar el peor
escándalo de la última década en materia
de filtraciones de documentos secretos
en Estados Unidos compareció por primera
vez ante un tribunal de Boston texeira
Fue capturado por el FBI y el jueves y
es acusado de retención y transmisión no
autorizada de información de defensa
nacional en virtud de la ley de
espionaje tanto el departamento de
Justicia como el pentágono son enfáticos
en señalar la gravedad del escándalo de
filtración
no se trata solo de llevarse documentos
a casa eso es por supuesto ilegal en sí
mismo se trata de la transmisión tanto
de la retención ilegal como de la
transmisión de los documentos todo el
mundo sabe aquí que los documentos al
final fueron transmitidos
este fue un acto criminal deliberado una
violación de las pautas creo que es
importante entenderlo
jackeyra un joven empleado de la guardia
Nacional de las fuerzas aéreas Se
declaró No culpable pero permanecerá
bajo arresto en la espera de juicio la
audiencia de tensión está prevista para
el 19 de abril si es hallado culpable
podría enfrentar 15 años de prisión los
documentos filtrados Aparentemente por
teixeira se cuentan en más de 100 y
revelan principalmente información
estratégicas sobre la guerra en Ucrania
también evidencian espionaje
estadounidense algunos de sus
importantes aliados como Corea del Sur y
circularon en redes sociales durante
varios días antes de que las autoridades
estadounidenses se percataran